quisiera preguntarle en primer lugar qué
balance hace usted de lo que ha sido
hasta el momento de la implementación
del acuerdo
santiago un saludo a ti ya todo el
equipo de frank 24 y muchas gracias por
esta oportunidad de pensar los temas de
colombia pues esta es una gran noticia
de que tengamos 5 años de la firma de un
acuerdo con una organización que fue
marcó la historia contemporánea de
colombia una guerrilla que que causó un
levantamiento armado con todos los
desastres que eso puede traer entonces
el lado bueno de este acuerdo es que la
mayoría de las farc la inmensa mayoría
de las farc dieron el paso a un acuerdo
de paz y ya han cumplido su palabra de
reconvertirse los movimiento político
hoy el partido común es con presencia en
el parlamento y la mala noticia es que
de parte de este gobierno el gobierno
del presidente iván duque no hay un real
compromiso para llevar adelante el
acuerdo o sea los puntos centrales del
acuerdo que tiene que ver con los temas
del desarrollo rural y con los temas de
transformar la política en un sentido
democrático siguen pendientes realmente
aquí nosotros hemos hablado de que el
gobierno simula el cumplimiento pero no
hay realmente un cumplimiento estricto
así de la firma de este acuerdo de paz
ahora la violencia en colombia continúa
a 5 años de la firma de los acuerdos por
ejemplo los asesinatos de líderes
sociales son un flagelo en varias
regiones del país crea usted que llegará
la paz duradera al país a colombiano
por lo que tú dices es cierto o sea
realmente hoy tenemos un nuevo ciclo de
violencia más pequeño o sea nosotros
venimos de una dinámica en la cual había
violencia política permanente llámese
guerrillas o paramilitares en por lo
menos la mitad del país hace 20 años y
hoy eso se ha reducido a una quinta
parte se hacía antes teníamos 500
municipios con dinámicas permanentes de
violencia llámese guerrillas o
paramilitares unos retando un orden
social y los otros defendiendo lo en los
últimos en en asocio con las fuerzas
estatales y eso hoy está mucho más
reducido ya no son 500 municipios y no
son 200 pero y tenemos tenemos muchos
menos muertos de la fuerza pública
tenemos muchos de los desplazamientos
pero sigue habiendo violencia contra
líderes sigue habiendo desplazamiento
sigue habiendo masacres entonces es
sigue habiendo una la un reto de
construcción de paz y fundamentalmente
con la última guerrilla que la guerrilla
lln y con otras dinámicas de más vientos
desde el reto de paz en colombia existe
pero para cambiar políticas que son en
las que promueven esta violencia acaba
usted de mencionar a la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional al el nn
considera usted que puede avanzarse un
acuerdo con esta guerrilla
pues la única forma de
superar la resistencia armada en la que
permanece ln es un acuerdo negociado en
ningún gobierno los apoyo controlar y
mucho menos derrotar entonces
desafortunadamente este gobierno está
acabando o sea estamos en la recta final
del gobierno del presidente o en duke
tendremos unas elecciones presidenciales
el próximo mayo y una segunda vuelta muy
seguramente en junio y será tarea del
próximo gobierno ojalá liderar una
negociación de paz con el lr porque la
única forma de resolver esto como se ha
hecho con todas las guerrillas y con los
paramilitares en el caso colombiano son
diálogos de negociación y así será con
el ln también